hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute mache ich mal was ganz
einfaches und ganz schnell es gibt
nämlich heute ein leckeres apfel
spekulatius dessert aus dem glas es geht
jetzt so langsam richtung weihnachten zu
und deswegen müssen wir gern spekulatius
mit ein bisschen zimt und äpfeln könnt
ihr alles zum winter und zu weihnachten
dazu und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal die zutaten
ich hab hier 500 gramm joghurt das ist
jetzt ein naturjoghurt mit 35 500 gramm
mascarpone 60 kommt zucker 60 milliliter
mädels etwas vanilleschote die habe ich
jetzt hier bereits zerkleinert ihr könnt
aber auch einfach vanillezucker nehmen
dann brauchen wir vier äpfel und etwas
zitronensaft daraus machen wir gleich
ein apfelmus
ich habe hier 300 gramm spekulatius
kekse etwas sind da werde ich etwa einen
teelöffel nehmen
hier habe ich 100 gramm gehackte mandeln
und die werde ich karamellisieren mit
zwei esslöffel zucker 2 s
und ich werde meinen spekulatius dessert
in kleine weckt lesern anrichten die
habe ich jetzt hier bereits vorbereitet
aber man kann die auch ganz normal in
normalen trinkgläsern zu bereiten und
die einfach später abdecken zuerst wird
jetzt das abfindungs vorbereitet und
dafür muss jetzt die äpfel einmal
schälen entkernen und viertel
die äpfel werden dann in kleine würfel
geschnitten und dann gebe ich sie in
einen topf und gibt da gleich den
zitronensaft dazu und ich werde das
apfelmus ohne zucker kochen weil die
creme und die spekulatius kekse schon
süß genug sind und hier gebe ich jetzt
anfield road und sagt mit dazu
und wer das jetzt auf höchster stufe
aufkochen und dann bei mittlerer stufe
etwa fünf minuten bis zehn minuten
weiter köcheln bis die äpfel weich sind
ihr könnt aber auch gern wenn ihr
möchtet ein bisschen bissfest lassen
soweit ich sitz machen und lassen
deswegen nur 5 minuten abschalten
zum abschluss gebe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen mehr erzeugt
ich werde heute allerdings dass nicht zu
einem muss für ihren sondern ich lass
das so ganz
also in würfelchen fing ich eigentlich
erst mit kompott
und in der zwischenzeit werde jetzt
schon mal meine kekse
einfach in eine schüssel rein müsst ihr
nicht ganz klein machen es reicht wenn
so ein paar bröckchen drin bleiben dann
hat man noch von
wenn ihr die kekse gern etwas feiner
haben wollt gibt es sehr einfach in der
gefriertruhe und rollt mit zone models
drüber so bekommt man sich schneller und
viel kleiner
mein apfelkompott ist jetzt fertig das
habe ich jetzt schon ausgeschaltet und
habt ihr eine pfanne heiß werden lassen
und gibt wasser rein damit ich jetzt
hier die mandeln leicht karamellisieren
kann
bisschen früher und dann wird sich da
gleich die farbe in
jetzt schon mal die man rein
ich habe jetzt auch relativ wenig zucker
genommen weil ich jetzt auch nicht will
dass das so süd es soll einfach so ein
bisschen karamellisieren
rühren bis wir das ganze schön karamell
kona
und jetzt werde ich noch die creme zu
bereiten dafür gebe ich einfach alles in
eine große schüssel rein
ihr könnt ihr übrigens auch stadt
joghurt zum beispiel quark nehmen aber
mit dem joghurt wird es ein bisschen
lockerer unerkannt eben
dominik gebe ich jetzt noch nicht rein
kann auch sein dass ich gar kein mensch
braucht je nachdem wie flüssig dass
jetzt gleich wird und jetzt frühere ich
das erstmal auf niedriger stufe damit es
ist nicht alles hier raus spritzt und
dann einfach so lange rühren bis das
ganze schön glatt ist und keine
klümpchen metern
ich gebe da jetzt noch ein bisschen
milch heim
unter nächste krems und fertig
ich stell dir ganz kurz kühl bis auf
mein apfelmus abgekühlt ist und dann
fange ich gleich an das dessert zu
schicken
ich werde jetzt mein dessert film und
schichten allerdings hatte ich gratis
auf dem stück vorgesehen
neben einer kleinen pause einen kaffee
und tee verkleckern und weiß jetzt
gerechnet wieder raus geht anscheinend
mit spüli uns macht den unterschied ob
man kaffee mit milch oder ohne
mitgezogen hat aber ich glaube ich noch
wirklich mal flecken spezial und tester
beim einfach alles aus und so ich hab
jetzt hier meine weckgläser vorbereitet
habe aber auch schon mal ein paar male
gläser hingestellt weil ich habe eine
große menge zubereitet also wenn ihr
eine kleine menge für vier personen
haben wollt dann können die helfen
jetzt werde ich so machen die erste
schicht wird jetzt creme sein
also blieb ich jetzt etwas training
achte darauf dass ich denn jetzt nicht
verschmutzen
damit zugleich auch von außen schön
aussieht
die zweite schicht sind dann die kekse
und die mandeln
die gebe ich jetzt auch drüber
die man sehen kann man jetzt einfach mit
den händen noch so ein bisschen
verkrümelt
die sind jetzt abgekühlt und jetzt
richtig schön knusprig
und dann einfach von ein bisschen
vergeben
dann kommen die äpfel mit dazu
die äpfel habe ich jetzt ganz
aufgebraucht da habe ich jetzt nur eine
mittlere schicht und jetzt gebe ich noch
mal eine schicht creme drauf und eine
schicht fixe größe
und jetzt kommt noch eine schicht
handeln auf
das ganze riecht hier schon richtig
lecker nach zimt und apple sind ohne
und den deckel kann ich da jetzt leider
nicht mehr drauf geben weil ich die
gesamte zufolge macht habt aber da
hatten einfach unbemerkt dass er ihm
klar
ich stelle jetzt kühl auch wenn ich sie
lieber gleich gern probieren würde aber
sie sollten mindestens für eine stunde
in den kühlschrank und dann können sie
gleich probieren die das denn jetzt kalt
und jetzt kann probiert werden
hinter der kamera steht heute nicht mein
mann ihr habt wahrscheinlich gemerkt die
kommentare fielen sondern mit karimow
von den fachstellen probieren
und am besten löffelmann von oben nach
unten
alles dabei
jetzt hat man hier die schöne creme dann
die weichen spekulatius ist er so ein
bisschen durch die creme und durch die
apple reich geworden
dann sehen sie es auch ein apfel und den
brand durch die mandeln
ich finde sich ein perfektes mentalist
was könnte man den alltag für den später
kann man zum beispiel andere kekse
nehmen butterkekse und löffel kekse
löffelbiskuits oder man nimmt auch im
kanton cheney habe ich auch schon ein
rezept rennen die schmecken auch sehr
lecker und statt des apfels kann man
auch irgendwas anderes nehmen
ihr könnt auch bereits fertig gekauft
des apfels benutzen
aber das war jetzt ein rezept geht
wirklich relativ schnell ich habe glaube
ich so etwa 20-30 minuten gebraucht
dafür und man hat einfach viel davon das
rezept gibt natürlich zum nachlesen of
sales blog.de
und ich freue mich darüber wenn ihr das
rezept nach macht mir bei instagram oder
facebook ein foto schickt und ich freue
mich schon wieder aufs nächste video
eben anschluss wenn ich euch noch einen
video verlinken wenn ihr noch nicht
genug von sally habt das könnt ihr euch
gerne auch mit anschauen und ich sage
einfach schiss einen schönen tag